[Music]
all right in got played news submitted
by Joe's toes smooth there we go black
hello clean its the carpets fault a
woman says she was tricked into marrying
a stranger while training for a new job
oh yeah dumbest clarinet what if we like
alright so you want this job huh and
then sign here you're married to me now
ha like that
that could totally cuz that's all it
really is do you want this job I do
allows you to come into the building
whenever you want all right so this
woman she's a 21 year old woman from
Hong Kong and she saw listing on
Facebook for a makeup artist
apprenticeship so she applied but then
the firm convinced her to switch over to
become a wedding planner instead which
is better which is not anything closely
related to issues yeah exactly it's like
an intern to a actual job right or
you're shadowing someone okay a facebook
lead on your facebook enjoy
well they she was blond Oh Hong Kong is
a little different I don't know so she
was given a week's worth of free
training in Hong Kong and then she was
told that she needed to participate in a
mock wedding in China in the mainland in
order for her to pass the course yes so
she went through it all she signed a
marriage application document like with
the room and then when she went back to
Hong Kong one of her classmates told her
like that was a scam like they were just
trying to get married to you so they
could come into Hong Kong whoa goes
further it wasn't just a prank yeah I
was married Sam did you know that was a
scam no but even with the accident oh
there there's so much better dude yes as
of right now she's still married but she
has applied for a divorce she doesn't
know who the man she married is but he's
just roaming around Hong Kong maybe
that's the real crazy rich Asians that
is they're smart yeah there have been a
lot of marriage scams happening like
mainland Chinese people marrying Hong
Kong people so they can go to Hong Kong
so there's a whole bunch of this how
[ __ ] up is China for people to always
try to run away from China we kind of
got the same thing going on here though
a little bit really people trying to run
away from America I think people just
say [ __ ] in America like we're all
moving to New Zealand or Canada or
whatever they already got accents for
the area from here anyway I'm trying to
Lee California I love California stuff
Ben there's so many different states now
like countries whatever I love
California the more places I go the more
I realized how four is the best yep I
haven't met anyone that was like I'm
moving to Canada because Trump and then
they actually moved I don't know anyone
honestly the only thing I love about
California compared to other places I've
been to is the weather and that's the
only reason why I'm not the [ __ ] food
or the redwood tree
yeah the freedom Yosemite Park there's
something about that place that I love
her I'm like I wish I could live the
weather where would you move to if the
weather was like California yeah what's
your second place I bet you I'll find
something shitty about that place but go
on course there's shitty things about
everywhere I want to catch you Joe with
the [ __ ] net but I'm a cashew I'm a
dreamer owner because I want everybody
to love California
it's like I have nothing to do with
California but because I was born and
raised here the shitty laws like you
always complain about
when we went to Malaysia right and then
we're on the [ __ ] radio station and
then they're like oh tell people how you
feel about a school or university I'm
like ah man you don't even [ __ ] need
that [ __ ] like pursue your passion with
wait wait wait
the government has this agenda to punish
school right now so you can't say that
and I'm like my freedom of speech has
never been threatened in my life that's
crazy and I'm like we couldn't even hug
ya I was like screw that oh yeah school
everyone I know I was offended I was
like really you want me to say that and
I was like you know what schools not for
everyone how about that can I say that
I'm telling you put captions voiceover
yeah cuz I'm like or you can do it you
might get arrested come on [ __ ] that is
some crazy [ __ ] I love America man
freedom with speeches it's great can't
take it lightly got [ __ ] hamburgers
like I love I like other places even
within America like you've just San
Francisco for example the architecture
and everything there's only California
the redwood trees though specifically LA
now at this point I like Texas I'd
rather be other places rather than LA
we've been down the one but the weather
is what keeps me here if I left here I
just picture myself back in sacrament
it's nice for now I like it weather here
Greece all year round
I heard ya never been there but I heard
well you know what else they got San
Diego they got a fucked-up economy
that's on the verge of collapse with a
lot of refugees that they can't deal
with our intelligence now but they got
the propolis though even like the east
car razy homeless person here dude you
know the eighth closest is coldest
button I know but like I really like the
architecture stuff that's the setting of
Americans that we don't really have age
like buildings like you go to any I'm
like mm mm years old it's gorgeous but
here it's like on the outside it looks
gorgeous and it looks gorgeous passing
by but then to live in it it's haunted
and then it's all [ __ ] up the
entrapment um but you can't live there
no I know but it's nice inside I'm just
saying like in general I just aged just
yeah yeah yeah well we're still a new
country compared to everywhere else they
have literally thousands of thousands of
years of history like where they're at
especially specifically we went to like
France mm we're just like you're a bay
preserve culture and religion because
it's tied to
like this I saw how pimps were inspired
I feel like all new money gaudy style
and like pants and everybody'll
everything is your hair
they're very inspired by the cars yeah
European cars I feel like so when you go
to these cheesy super gaudy things right
like like gold [ __ ] this and bad and
like all these crazy pillars I was like
I know where they're what they're trying
to do is they're trying to be like the
ballers of Old Europe like the old kings
and queens but for some reason it kind
of looks the same but not really you
know I mean it's like how come the the
Palace of Versailles can do the goldleaf
[ __ ] and they can make it all nice and
it looks dope use the same materials put
it in Vegas now it looks like some old
Italian mom decorated everything it's
tight though I like it there I do too
palace well there's a different style
man that's just so crazy it's sick huh
dude I can't even imagine like how they
even built that [ __ ] back in the day how
they lived there there was no bathroom
in there mmm in that crazy no poop over
the rails are the [ __ ] stairs man
yeah creative it's so crazy cuz they're
so like [ __ ] nice and like ballin
they got [ __ ] so much money it really
did I just picture this lady just
[ __ ] lifting up her at 14 layer dress
just know they had man they had buckets
for that yeah it was a pen that they
would slide under there and then they
just did their thing
oh it's like an umbrella
they just hoped it on out diarrhea
there's a spray to the side show that
diarrhea well day wipe was before TV I'm
just grass maybe a servant [ __ ] wiped
it out hang yes I have the resume of who
else you've worked for because I don't
really want that dudes old hand pooed
you know like in America and there in
the world in where would you want to
live that you've gone see i if it was in
America I would choose like Chicago the
murder capital it's just so the weather
like in the winter know in the summers
is humid the bean I like it or Austria
like all the bullets all the wind I
could agree with that but Chicago's
weird
they got Javid then use a capital
although man yeah good music I mean I've
been to Chicago too but never once that
I go damn this is different it just felt
like something Cisco yeah a little
colder yeah I like these costs that much
just the way they deal with trash in our
everyone just takes and just throws it
on the front of the street yup and they
killed Tupac so I could never love them
the way I still have reminiscences of
that East Coast West Coast turf war you
know so I'm gonna what I'm glad I just
don't feel right 20 years ago can't take
you to Vegas anymore dude what's that
Vegas died I know that's where he died
but that's okay cuz there's a memorial
there but who did it
East Coasters right maybe I agree though
like East Coast is kind of just it's
different man like it feels so different
like he's really cool at the culture
they have a lot of culture they have a
lot of culture but those feel bad it's
just fat worried me though it's fast
what their culture to me is like is just
mean you got a lot of history here oh
you [ __ ] filthy animal I'm like damn
you're just [ __ ] offended right now
they're like ah I talk at all though the
food is like closer oh man yeah that
each other and there's a lot of things
to do to look at you just like wow I was
like the culture is there it's just
really fast that's all yeah and everyone
dresses nice man I feel like we dress
like we're always going to Walmart here
in California I love woman out there
almost tight and we want to New York
they look so good oh good sponsored much
anyways so they're agreeing with me
about it's great see you don't say yeah
sponsored all day or so yes sir by
Walmart they dropped a brand deal with
me so I'm still saying Walmart I okay
all right
their veggie sections fired
[Music]